wheel of fortune is doing something that
they've never done before
i talked to pat sajak and vanna white
about that
and also the late great alex trebek
we recently lost your good friend alex
trebek and what was it that made alex
so special i knew alex for almost 40
years and he's just been
a good friend through the years i've
gotten to know his wife and his kids
and just on a professional level he's
done so much i mean when i started the
show
you know alex had already done probably
a half a dozen maybe more game shows
here in in canada before pack got his
gig hosting wheel of fortune
he was a weatherman in los angeles vanna
was a model
i wear a lot of nice clothes on the show
and two thousand dollar gowns and they
all have to be returned
and after 38 seasons and 7
315 episodes van has given us some
pretty amazing fashion moments
spanning four decades well people ask me
what is your favorite outfit and i have
to say the comfortable ones
i've worn over 7 000 dresses i remember
a white one with pink feathers for some
reason that stands out
when she comes out i can always tell if
she's happy with the dress or not
there's a certain look in her eye
tomorrow the show will make history
crossing over into prime time for a
special celebrity edition
the first of eight episodes includes snl
alum leslie jones
grey's anatomy chandra wilson and
legendary skateboarder tony
it's a positive thing we're giving away
lots of money to lots of charities
a c one c
is there a celebrity who you feel would
be a great
real player other than you kevin well i
mean look i'm waiting for my invitation
i'm waiting i think it's been lost
we'll work on that
you